here we are we have come to this this is
the review of the epic conclusion of the
Mass Effect trilogy cue miracle of sound
if you get that song then you get the
song if you don't I got to wonder why
you're watching a Mass Effect 3 review
unless you just like this face in which
case I guess it's okay in any case Mass
Effect 3 so it has been a long road to
the end of Mass Effect a long enjoyable
road because Mass Effect is one of the
best sci-fi dramas out there it just it
is what it is and in my opinion they
nailed Mass Effect 2 so perfectly I was
thinking if they don't change anything
in terms of gameplay or structure for
Mass Effect 3 they'll be fine so how was
Mass Effect 3 in a word it was great so
in Mass Effect 3 Shepards back with the
Alliance and the Reapers have come and
it's a dark day for Humanity and every
race in the galaxy so the Reapers are
wiping everything out you got to get
your crew together and battle the
Reapers not just your crew though you
have to unite the entire galaxy there's
some conflict among some of the Galactic
species in Mass Effect's so to unite
them is going to be a challenge but
that's part of the experience of Mass
Effect now in terms of characters Mass
Effect just nails it there are so many
moments in this game where I'm like dude
man tears if Mass Effect 3 is going for
a very deep emotional impact on you they
nailed it and in that I feel it's
important to play Mass Effect 1 and 2
before 3 because that's where you bond
with the characters that's where you
bond with your crewmates and friends so
when things happen to them in Mass
Effect 3 it's just tragic if you played
the other games you've spent over a
hundred hours bonding with these people
because you get so attached to your crew
which is pretty much what you're
supposed to do you're supposed to care
about the people you're with and who
you're fighting with the Mass Effect
saga completely takes care of that Mass
Effect 3 it's one of those games
depending on how you play the end of
Mass Effect 2 some characters may or may
not be alive in 3 I'm kind of interested
to see how that would even work or if
some missions just aren't going to be in
the game because I had everyone alive
but what if I didn't there's some
missions really like that mission would
be impossible if those two guys were
dead those two guys could be dead
interesting stuff right there the
gameplay is very similar to Mass Effect
2 almost identical and in terms of the
gameplay being a lot like Mass Effect 2
I can't imagine playing Mass Effect
without a sniper rifle
I mean honestly in this game like - you
get the best sniper rifle in the game
you're just destroying guys in one hit
one thing that was in Mass Effect 2 that
was not in Mass Effect 3 where the loyal
team
missions I really felt that the loyalty
missions in Mass Effect 2 were a really
cool way to bond with your crew member
you know just kind of see what makes
them tick see what they're going through
Mass Effect 3 doesn't have those loyalty
missions Mass Effect 3 even has that one
CSEC dude from Mass Effect 2 who's
voiced by salt I from Battlestar
Galactica Commander Shepard these are
dark days mo knows you can't help but
vision sul ty from Battlestar Galactica
some of the interaction I kind of found
weird in every interaction in the old
game you have the dialogue circle every
time you talk to someone unless they
didn't want to talk to you if they just
start talking and you don't have the
dialogue circle you're like all right
that's just extra dialogue I'm out
however in this one some of the
important dialogue actually happens
without the dialogue circle and it
throws you for a loop at first you're
like I've spent two games being
accustomed to dialogue circle important
no dialogue circle negate able now no
dialogue circle means might be important
I suppose the same amount of dialogue
between you and the character you're
talking to you is going back and forth
with or without the dialogue circle but
you just kind of feel like you're not
hurting the conversation in the way that
you would like you did in the last two
massive bad games still great dialogue
Bell multiplayer is really fun I mean
for being a multiplayer there's just
kind of thrown into a game that's really
based off of single-player campaign I
felt the multiplayer was great and it
has that left4dead light kind of feeling
you know it plays like left4dead but
instead of zombies coming after you have
Cerberus troops or you have
indoctrinated aliens coming after you or
Geth pick your poison point as bad guys
coming after you and your friends you
got to wipe them out and is it hours
upon hours of fun yeah you betcha
another thing I found kind of light and
insignificant in Mass Effect 3 was my
romance in Mass Effect 1 I romance
Ashlee Mass Effect 2 Miranda Mass Effect
3 I went back to the end of Mass Effect
2 and romance nobody because I heard if
you like cheated on Ashley even though
she bitched out in the second one we're
going to have consequences I just didn't
want to deal with consequences or drama
so I romance nobody in two in three I
dealt with consequences and drama cuz
she's still pissed at you for joining
Cerberus after that she doesn't talk to
you at all and then at the very end of
the game you're like oh yeah I love you
love you too kind of made my romance
insignificant my friend was like I
romance telly and it was awesome because
she's great she's cool I was like yeah
actually is the most useless piece of
girlfriend in the entire galaxy so
don't ever romance Ashley however Mass
Effect does a good job showing you that
the character interactions and the
emotional connection you feel with your
crew is more important than any romance
options like Garris I was closer to
garrison this game than any character in
a game ever
Garrus for the win awesome war buddy
dude that dude is the
yes then there's the end in a game that
is so built up on choice I felt the
ending was kind of disappointing all
right by kind of I mean the more you
think about it the more you hate it I'm
not going to tell you everything about
the ending so don't worry no spoilers
here however I will do a review a video
on the ending itself because it just is
worthy of its own video and I'll break
down what I liked about it what I didn't
like about it what I think they should
change with DLC somehow so keep your eye
out for that in short I felt like the
choices you made Mass Effect 1 and Mass
Effect 2 should affect the ending of
Mass Effect 3 in the end it just kind of
doesn't you get the ending however if
you're going on the John Locke from lost
perspective or as I like not about the
destination Jack it's about the journey
then yes the road to the end of Mass
Effect 3 is one of the most emotionally
gripping and epic things I've ever
played in my life so beautiful dude so
many times like I'm telling you tears I
have the soundtrack because it's just
worth having it is definitely worth
playing although you will be conflicted
about the end but again another review
for another time so have you played the
Mass Effect games have you not if you
haven't now's a good time to start what
did you think of them what's your
favorite one of the three and what's
your favorite sci-fi epic game also that
because the last video I did I think I
asked for your favorite sci-fi drama in
space now we're going to do game
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more whatever uniform
you can find like a Kroger
and the Shepherd